you
[Music]
so thanks everyone for for coming to a
somewhat different location for this
talk
I'm delighted today to be introducing
Martin Dorey who is a professor at the
University of Amsterdam where you've
been for about 20 years now I believe
and I've known him for many years now in
information retrieval circles he's done
a ton of work in various information
retrieval workshops from clay to Trek
and covered an amazingly broad set of
topics from document blog analysis core
web ranking expertise finding social
media analysis some touching some on
neural models in information retrieval
but I found out last night when I was
reading up for on his background that he
also had a ten year career in modal
logic he had a rockstar paper there that
has almost a book I guess it was that
has almost 4,000 citations and about 10
years into his career shifted to
thinking about information access really
broadly considered and I think it's I'll
find out more this afternoon later about
the the motivations for that shift but
here today he's he's he leads it at
Amsterdam a very large lab I don't know
how many students are in it dozens yeah
and one of the things that I've always
valued about students who've worked with
Martin I said we have one who did a
postdoc with him I see Julia many of you
know Katja Hoffman many others have have
blessed us with the internships over the
many years is that the students come in
with this amazing mix of a strong
theoretical foundation grounded in real
world problems and so Martin
historically has done an amazing job of
working with various government agencies
local companies to really educate a you
know a generation of information
retrieval people who think not just
about academic publications but also
asking the right questions and so today
he's going to talk to us I'm delight
to see this on conversational based
systems specifically focusing on how
people can engage with search engine
result pages in a way that is much more
than your traditional one-shot search in
and out search and so Martin welcome and
look forward to your time all right
thank you for the introduction sue it's
great to be here I think we have about
an hour the main point of this
presentation is not for me to lead to
reach the last slide but for you to pick
up something so if you have questions
along the way please
just interrupt me and I'll try and
answer them so just to give a tiny bit
of background and to follow up on what
Suja said
so I'm a professor at the University of
Amsterdam the title is university
professor of AI and I are that sort of
means I've mostly focus on machine
learning related problems that have to
do with search with recommendation with
conversational assistance the the team
continues to grow and not just the
technology aspect but also the around
the implications of the technology that
we helped develop one other thing and
that touches on the second thing that
sue just mentioned is these
collaborations between academia and
industry or other non-academic
stakeholders so together with a group of
colleagues a couple of years ago well
two years ago now roughly we decided
that maybe we should structure this a
bit more formally and we found that this
National Innovation Centre for AI that's
that's a collection of lab every lab is
at least 5 PC students but in one case
it has over 15 students these are funded
by those companies or governmental
organizations around the shared research
agenda and the reason we do them is
because we think we get better science
if
we create impact with that science so
the all these labs are output focused so
they they collect problems with these
companies or Whitney's governmental
agencies and try to also test their
outcomes in those settings and in many
cases it means that the PC students who
work on in these labs spend part of
their time with these companies or with
these governmental organizations so
typically that's two days a week but in
some cases for instance one of the labs
is with Bush the German company they
don't have an R&D department in the
Netherlands so the students go to their
German R&D departments a couple of times
per year and spent some time in Germany
in there in the bush labs and the rest
of the time they interact over Skype or
phone or short-term visits all right so
so far with our collaboration with
Microsoft research has been a bit more
ad hoc we've actually just one of our
the students who was funded by a
microsoft research grant defended two
weeks ago co supervisor also by yuliya
and and my colleague max welding machine
learning works a lot with Chris Bishop
in Cambridge anyway that's a bit of
background so the talk that I'd like to
give today is based on some finished
work but mostly working progress and
these are people involved with that work
in progress
you know some of them Marta was here
this summer I'm here now and some of you
have also interacted with swetlana for
instance around track cast recently and
because as well so and the the view that
we the view of IR that we hold in my
team is this is all around
all about connecting people to
information we don't really care in
which way as long as it's about this
connecting people to information so
sometimes we do have an explicit
statement of a need sometimes we don't
all we have is a a profile of some kind
and increasingly this landscape is
changing were from single-shot as as sue
said in the opening were moving to multi
turn setups you probably know these
numbers much better than I do
we're the sort of queries that that are
being seen are changing from a
traditional desktop setting to other
settings you probably have as I said
more accurate numbers and more
up-to-date numbers and I you have access
to but the point here is is changing in
interesting ways it's changing in ways
up to some degree for surely for our
people go back decades
right there are old papers but friends
by Nick Belkin going back to the late
1970s early 1980s where he discusses at
length the idea of searches conversation
multiple terms with active search with
knowledge elicitation on the part of the
system etc there was a nice almost
position statement and organizing our
thoughts around the topic paper by by
Nick and and Philip a couple of years
ago I think that certainly for many I
our folks felt like a good positioning
of of these conversational developments
as you know a lot of the work that's
happening around conversational search
is is either task oriented or it's very
factoid ish oriented but of course
there's more than that a nice example
actually came out of Marty's internship
which is neither task oriented in a very
strict setting that we know from task
oriented dialogues
systems you know booked a ticket or some
such task nor a factoid these talking
with documents so the focus there is on
increasing productivity somehow using a
conversational agent and in this case on
the right hand side you see an example
factoid QA given a document you might
want to use that document to answer a
question like what is the capital of
France and then the assistant would have
to say Paris the documents entered
assistant would do something else you
could you would for instance ask it do
we mention our mission statement in this
document or when did we last update this
document or so partly about the content
but also partly about the provenance
partly about the metadata of this
document and this is what the assistant
would have to say in reply for instance
yeah on page 2 and then it extracts some
information from the document so the
that work is interesting for a number of
reasons it's it's a different type of
conversational assistant we do so many
things for us to discover there right
what sort of functionality would people
expect from this what type of questions
would they if they have this function of
the what type of questions would they
submit and on the system side how can we
recognize these documents entered
questions and and separate them from say
more traditional factoid questions
here's another example that some work
with Svetlana that we published last
year talked with the data set so you
have a gigantic data set structured
semi-structured as gazillion columns and
now you want to answer questions about
this data set and that doesn't mean you
you translate natural language questions
into SQL or Sparkle
no it means you slowly reveal the
different attributes the different
qualities that are in that data set and
so that model needs to maintain a model
that you would device for this would
need to maintain some sort of a notion
of the columns that you've already
revealed how long ago that was
find out whether someone is still
exploring or Ozora is ready to zoom in
on something another example also with
Lana that is work on conversational
access to very large collections of
items this could be for instance the
collection of all the paintings that
Rijksmuseum in Amsterdam has and now you
to talk to that collection what does
that mean what does that mean in terms
of engagement what does it mean in terms
of answer formats
sometimes it's what is it new to
translate to metadata do you translate
to maybe visual information now so these
are three examples of conversational
interaction that differ from task
oriented dialogue systems and from more
factoid ish QA now we go back to another
old paper 2004 Rosen Levinson
understanding usual goals in web search
so this came I think two or three years
after Andre brothers paper on in which
he proposed navigational informational
and I think he said he used
transactional goals and then Rosen
Levinson called these resource goals and
it both papers did various types of
analysis both I do using doing user
studies but also by doing large-scale
classification experiments on how many
of the queries that they see are
informational and consistently it's 42
60% and some of them are very factoids
and so those are the ones that are maybe
for this talk I'm not so interested in
others are much more a broader that
wouldn't just be a single entity or a
short list of entities that would be
appropriate
as an answer but could be different
perspectives it could be guiding users
from entities to relations between
entities the rosen levels on paper has a
number of very concrete suggestions you
can see some of them over here directed
questions closed questions open
questions undirected questions advice
questions locate questions list
questions and and so on and so I'm
interested in and we're interested in
the more the broader types of questions
that come up here and of course we have
a over the years we've developed a
pretty effective way of returning
results and response to such questions
and they they offer a lot of richness
they hide a lot of uncertainty if we're
not quite sure what it is that the user
is looking for well we just give give
that user a very complex page with many
many options and then leave it to the
user to to zoom in on one panel or
another right so here I think my example
query was Macau or Macau with a spelt
with a o or a U and then you can you can
see the uncertainty the search engine
has in response to this query right
things to do Macau the knowledge panel
knowledge Institute's questions asked
about Macau etc and you know we've that
works in many cases right the the system
doesn't really have to understand what
the user is looking for just needs to
offer sufficiently many options so that
the the the conversation the interaction
sorry can continue its diverse its rich
and in in some degree to some degree
it's it doesn't get to the heart of the
matter
namely understanding what the user wants
so what I'm interested in is this
combination all that richness all that
diversity all these options but now
conversational how do we convey this as
what is a reasonable response Macau or
Macau to Macau Macau maybe it's what do
you mean and so the question that were
pursuing and directly or somewhat
indirectly and quite a few of our
ongoing projects has to do with the the
bullet up here as the way in which we we
interact with information changes how
can we support conversations that are as
rich and as diverse and as enabling as
these complex herbs but then maybe in a
spoken way or on a tiny screen or in a
line-by-line
chat interface a warning or spoiler I
don't have the answer but I do want to
tell you share with you a bit of where
we are on this so as I said a lot of
this is working progress some of it is
about to be published in a few months
so let's take a step back and walk
through a couple of examples to to make
this all a bit clearer
right so here we have alert system and
were interested in money made by movies
how much money did a movie make and so
we could submit that as a query and then
we would get back a list of snippets and
from one of these snippets we will be
able to get back a number and we don't
actually have to be very smart to do
that right if I remember some of your
older work so with the early TREC QA
just a lot of data will and and knowing
what a number looks like is good enough
another example you know a human asking
a question or a system asking a question
and then getting a response what what
did you think of the title well the
title pretty much describe the level of
the humor in this Ben Stiller movie huh
I agree
do you know if it made any money yeah it
made two hundred and eighty million
pretty good right so here's our
reasonably natural conversation with a
system right and it has the answer and
it has this the the number in right
there it has the answer but it also has
some conversational bits and pieces
around it that make it fit naturally in
and what went on before another example
here we're talking about movie plots and
again the ranked list of snippets and in
red here bombed arrives in st.
Petersburg and meets a CIA contact Jack
Wade conversation in a conversational
setting that was a good scene what did
you like about a movie some human system
I liked his friend Jack Wade human
system I love the part where bond
arrives in st. Petersburg and meets his
CIA contact Jack Wade now again this
feels natural why and it feel and it's
informative right it there's a
connection in black and there's a
snippet of text extracted from one of
the search engine snippets and so those
are the sort of things that that we have
in mind when we talk about sir based
conversations so they bought that talks
to a search engine looks at the SERP
that comes back that's produced and then
uses the SERP to inform its next
utterance and if you unpack that a bit
what does it mean so here's this the
same as before but now we're unpacking
it right we need to fire a query we need
to understand what the question is
actually trying to achieve then we need
to select passages from the assure that
is produced we may have to summarize
those passages and then use this to
generate the response okay
and so that's a richer than a generative
model typically is right because that's
we have a document collection we have a
language model trained on that document
collection and then questions come in
and responses are produced by this by
this language model it's a fair bit
richer than that so let's simplify it a
bit cut out the retrieval step and just
pretend that we have one document given
so we have an ongoing conversation and
then at each term we get one document
that were allowed to use to produce a
good reference a good response this has
been introduced in the literature
just a few years back it's called
background based conversation this one
document is the background and you can
use it to inform the responses okay so
rather than that complex picture that we
had with the multiple steps this is the
the simpler picture we now have
conversational history one document
produce your next response so here what
is the example what is the physician's
assistant and we got some response and
then the next question what are the
educational requirements required to
become one and then the the the snippets
on the right-hand side has this part in
blue that says the most common
educational requirements are the
completion of the row and that is then
used by the bot to reproduce the the
utterance in blue on the left hand side
another example from one of the test
sets that is now available that are now
available for background based
conversations it's about scary movies
and so we have this ongoing conversation
he went one was it worth money
she went to cheesy and trashy but very
entertaining I bet it didn't win any
awards in comes the background
information that one document is given
that provides us with background
information about scary movie three
various things awarded one how much
money had made and we also see some
additional information namely there was
a scary movie for and there's a scary
movie 5 and now what do different models
do that produce responses well the
typical sequence to sequence model with
attention could produce something on
this I think it made an amount of
dollars
g-e-t to be you could check out scary
movie , for so you see a bit of a
problem here that the entity is slightly
messed up by Def another recent model
has nicely extracted a coherent chunk of
text from the background document but
this conversation leads somewhere out of
place the ground truth for for this
example in the in the test collection
has this you are wrong MTV movie and TV
Awards 2004 best cameo and so here what
do you see again something that fits the
answer together with the conversation
that went on before that you are wrong
directly in reply to this and then the
answer this extracted from the
background so that's one of the key
challenges in his background based
conversations namely there's knowledge
selection extract from the background
document a good text fragment that you
can use in your next response the two in
the literature you'll see two types of
approach to this problem one is an
extraction based the others generation
based the extraction based ones simply
copy material from the background
document into the response and often
what they would do or the way that are
organizes they learn pointers to extract
to identify startings
starting point and end point of suitable
spans so here's an by def is one example
of an extraction based BBC system write
it nicely cuts out a good coherent
fragment but it does not have anything
conversational
the generation based ones used the
background material to influence the
responses that they generate and it's
they don't always have an easy time
using the background information
successfully so often they appear to be
fairly natural but they may break the
the units extracted from the background
so you see that with cheated P here for
example has a reasonable or reasonably
well fitting conversational bit here you
should check out but then it has
slightly messed up the extracted bit now
we've we've looked at this problem and
try to understand what's going on here
and whether and try to understand
whether we could improve on what we've
just seen extraction and generation
cells to produce better responses that
do use the background we're not the
first to do this others have tried to do
that as well for instance usually these
generation based systems are
encoder/decoder
based they often adopt a local
perspective meaning that you generate
one token at a time and then one thing
you could do is for these entities that
you've recognized in the in the
background information simply viewed
them as one token so that you wouldn't
cut them up you are the general you
select it or not but then you select all
of it some approaches have tried that
other approaches have tried to use a
knowledge graph in the back and
basically that amounts to do the same
thing namely which next entity from the
knowledge graph to to select and use for
your response
so our idea to try to overcome some of
these shortcomings here is to complement
that local perspective so what is the
next thing next thing that we should
generate with a global perspective and
let me try and explain what that means
it's it's going to be published in early
family in a triple-a paper and so it
follows this encoder/decoder idea that
most generation based BBC systems have
so we have an encoder for the background
information that one document we have an
encoder for the context the conversation
that has been ongoing until now we have
something for local knowledge selection
and basically think of that as which
what is the next token we should
generate and we have this global
knowledge selection that tries to
understand what the conversation is
about and tries to keep track of that
and that global understanding of the
ongoing conversation influences the
choice is that the local knowledge
selection will make so let me explain
that in one or two slides
so first the global dollar selection so
at the top here assume that we have
encoded the background knowledge and
we've encoded the conversational context
of what has been interact the things
that have been set until now we learn a
topic transition vector by looking at
the relation between these two and
codings
and that topic transition vector is then
used by the local knowledge selection to
decide whether or not to go for the next
term or to go for from the language
model or to go for the background
information so that's what happens at
each decoding time step the the local
knowledge selection outputs a response
token that's either from the vocab areso
produced by the language model or it's
selected from from the background
information and it's the global and all
the selection module that dictates which
one to which way to go I have a few
examples here that I want to show let me
show this example first so we have this
is our dialogue context I loved all the
tricks and and traps sorry I loved all
the tricks and traps kevin created human
- me - i loved one using a tape recorder
he tapes a message and slows down his
voice placing a hotel reservation he
went one that was too funny the hotel
staff didn't believe him though here's
the background information later that
evening
he intends to access Kevin's room but
Kevin fooled him into thinking that he
has walked in on his father causing the
concierge to flee home alone - is a
carbon copy but it's also much better
and more composure
that's a background now the background
based conversation system needs to
produce a response gtp that's a
generation based system
it's a classic and I watched the first
two movies every year okay see from a
conversational point of view seems to be
a really natural follow-up but it
doesn't use the background information
another generation based approach breath
net will also be published Tripoli I
write away in a few months that it was
so sad when he intends to access Kevin's
room but Kevin pulls him into thinking
that he has walked in on his father so
we have a mixture here of something
generated by the language model and and
copied from the the background but it's
it's not fluent its generation based
again we're only using the local
information meaning basically the
language model I know it was a carbon
copy but it's also much better and more
complex a movie than the first now
global and local so true so here we have
a sort of a conversational hook
conversational linked to what went on
before and then a bit of material copied
from the background information okay so
I hope this illustrates some to some
degree what these different models do
that only have a local perspective
versus ones that also have a more global
personal perspective now let's go back a
second to these what we have here is at
the top the ground truth knowledge
selection and then the the probability
of tokens being selected sort of
probability on the y-axis the tokens
listed on the x-axis we then have that
that's a ground truth we then have the
global approach the global to local
approach and only the local approach so
according to the ground truth those are
the two tokens to be selected the global
knowledge selection
module is somewhat uncertain it's things
that there may be some good response
here as well as there that's only global
global and local together ends up here
and local has various uncertainties some
potential responses that it thinks that
are here and there are somewhere further
down there and that's typically what we
see in lots of the cases that we
analyzed uncertainty in the local
knowledge selection uncertainty in just
using the global knowledge selection
that's only using the the background
document and uncertainty reduced when we
combine global and local sure how this
one is selected
why we selected in this illustration I
have to go back to the paper and I can
do it after the talk the numbers refer
to discard the ongoing discard the
discussion in the paper yeah now there's
a small number of data sets for these
background based conversations this is
one that was introduced last year it's
built for movie chats each response is
expressly generated either by copying
and or modifying censors from the
background information and the
background itself consists of plots
comments and reviews about those movies
and then this is collected from a bunch
of websites I think it's IMDB Rotten
Tomatoes yeah and so different types of
results on the right-hand side whether
we take a single response as the ground
truth or multiple responses multiple
potential responses as ground truth at
the bottom that's actually more
interesting here so out of out of public
conversations in the dataset we sampled
500 and then asked human laborers to
check each of the system generated
responses for naturalness
informativeness appropriateness and
humanists to which degree does this look
like a response that could have been
generated by a human and we did that for
with three Assessors per per response
for GT TP for ref net and for the model
I've been talking about
at least one Assessor thought it was
natural or informative or appropriate or
looked like a human could have generated
it or at least two and so naturally the
numbers for at least one are higher than
the numbers for at least two on the
whole the numbers for the global and
local model are higher than the numbers
for for earlier models generation based
models except for this informativeness
so ref net is is a a generative model
and apparently according to our
Assessors it tends to generate slightly
more informative responses than the
global and local knowledge selection
model
okay what's next so remember this was
the the simplified picture of background
based conversations we have the normal
conversation on the left and then at
every turn we get one document to help
us with the generation of the next
response the original picture was more
complex this survey for surveys
conversations and what I'd like to do
next is walk you through each of these
steps that are numbered there
so search query understanding selecting
passages summarizing those passages and
then using those to generate a response
so pretty formulation that was the
that's the first right how do we from
the ongoing conversation how do we
produce good queries that will result in
useful SERPs that we can use to generate
responses now there's a there's tons of
work that you could use and as a
starting point for this certainly track
casts this year as a work that's
immediately relevant here but there's
there's actually also all the work last
year two years ago reinforcement
learning to generate query
reformulations this is a somewhat older
paper even from 2015 also reinforcement
learning for producing queries and as
the conversation evolves so as the
conversation evolves that means after
each turn you regenerate suggested
formulations reformulations using not
just the the original query from the
user but also what the user
had a subsequent query what they may
have inspected what they may have
reformulated etc question understanding
so step two what is the user trying to
achieve in this ongoing conversation so
that's all about trying to infer
preferences likes dislikes recognizing
entities in the queries relations
between these entities and in some cases
actually learning when to ask an
explicit question for instance in the
Macao or Macao setting maybe just ask
what the user is trying to achieve here
passage selection so in some cases to be
able to answer a question or have enough
snippets to produce our next utterance
it's not good enough to just have a
single document a single snippet
sometimes we need to do actually go down
the ranked list of in the syrup quite
deeply this is a paper that we published
earlier this year at wisdom also with
who sign who was here last summer I
think that does that passage
summarization so that's clear that you
need this but there's some interesting
new twists here because perhaps we
should do the summarization not in a
unimodal context but in a multi-modal
context and also we should what should
we optimize for in this case is it to
get the best summary or is it to get the
best interaction resulting from the
summary
next step response generation so what if
we have we've gone through that the
whole loop fired queries got to Serb
extracted right passages summarize them
and now use it use this summary for
response generation a recurring problem
with many of those generation based
models is a repetition the same work
being selected over and over again so
liqueur to put it differently a lack of
diversity let's we have some work at
double double this year that tries to
address that problem
another one is appropriateness so if
you're generating responses probably you
want to avoid adult content but there
are in many cases there are different
types of things you want to avoid as
well what if it's a sensitive topic and
and and the what response I don't care
it's not appropriate in many cases and
so understanding this problem of what is
appropriate what is not what is a
malevolent response what is not I don't
think we've addressed that and I think
we shoot so what right now we're trying
to build the data set with where we have
where we propose a number of categories
of malevolent responses and we should
finish that this week yeah this week and
then hopefully we'll be ready with the
data set and some classification
experiments by the time of ZAR i think
it's an important problem and not as a
typical problem that in our community
we've looked at of course we've done
spam filtering we've done lots of
quality control textual quality control
work ethic at ZAR but this is different
because here we're generating and then
we should suppress some of them and the
content that we're generating
what else ah right right so as I said at
the beginning we try to not just build
technology that connects people to
information but also look at the
implications of this technology and that
that to make that concrete that means
you look at things like the transparency
confidentiality fairness explain ability
in this context has a number of
interesting readings explainable to whom
if we have this agent that's learning
from responses from questions and
responses that it receives from users
you might want to be able to to trace
back
why produced a certain utterance when
did it pick that up so we have a paper
at ICML last year that tries to do that
was inspired by this very problem we see
your bot generate a response that is
totally off how did that come about some
recent work at ACL and only published on
archive so far tries to use a knowledge
graph or some sort of reasoning over
entities relations between entities in a
knowledge graph for explanations and
these types of it explanations help
developers but could also be used to
help users so what if a bot says
something and it expresses an opinion
we also try to provide some sort of
motivation for for this opinion here is
an example on the right hand side how do
you how do we do that okay I'd like to
wrap up so the motivation here was with
for many years we've been using Serbs
there's something fantastic about these
complex Serbs
because of the diversity the richness
the the sort of bundling of many
starting points on on a single page the
motivation was can we to which degree
and how can we translate some of this
into a conversational setting what I've
shared with you is some early steps in
this direction the general it is some
advances on scaled-down versions of the
problem and some challenges and
emissions and in the last few slides
there's still a lot to do here obviously
and here's a whole bunch of references
both all the new ones that fell into the
presentation Thanks right so the
question was I talked about a complex
system how do I think about this from
the point of view of actually building
the system and implementing it alright
so what we've done with that global to
local knowledge selection system was
looked at it as and as an end-to-end
optimization end-to-end training problem
that's great for academic research it's
maybe not
immediately the the the most obvious way
to go from from our practical point of
view where you would probably want to
have a few more intermediate steps where
you could intervene if something goes
wrong and you have a better
understanding what goes wrong if
something goes wrong this this sort of
end-to-end vs. component based what is
it
dilemma you see in many conversational
systems the truth is probably somewhere
in the middle yeah Matt you had a
question
right so the we don't we no longer see
the SERP we knew it once existed but and
we knew it offered an incredible
richness of information and of it could
also hide a lot of uncertainty of the
search engine but I didn't need to make
a choice as long as it offered enough
starting point for a user now we no
longer show that to a user the user just
talks to a device could even be this
device and I don't know and but we do
want to convey all that richness that
was originally in the SERP and maybe
that was the wrong answer or maybe it's
there indeed could also be yes and so
how do we convey some of that rich you
know some of the diversity how do we
circumvent the fact that we can no
longer be as uncertain as we could allow
ourselves to be on a syrup
certainly we need to change things in
that search engine if you go back to
sorry the question was do we need to is
it right to say that what I've been
presenting is just a conversational
interface to a traditional search engine
or is something sure that something else
happened now if we go back to Matt's
question my answer to Matt's question
how do we deal with the uncertainty and
resolving the uncertainty now today we
don't actually we don't really have to
estimate how how confident we are with
one the results from one vertical versus
the results from another vertical we
just show both of them and of course
they have probably a ranked list or some
order in in the panels from these
verticals but hey we don't need to align
this in this conversational setting
where we have one response at a time
only no we do have to have a global
confidence measure a global sense of
certainty or uncertainty across the
results that we have so that has certain
implications
maybe certainly in a more traditional
federated search you don't actually have
to align the confidence values across
the verticals no so that would be one
example I also think that
[Music]
another important aspect that has to
change is implicit understanding the
implicit feedback interpreting it also
being more proactive and understanding
how and when to do this if you do too
often you know people will get fed up
and it's not helpful but you should
probably do it more often than we do it
with a traditional SERP you know I think
you were first yeah okay so the question
is what is the right mental model here
is it a broker that decides for the user
or that displays some of the
uncertainties yeah I think that's a
great question and I don't have the
answer I am moving back and forth
between this is a traditional most
librarian information in intermediary
model on the one hand and someone who
would give me more control myself and it
says well you know I don't know here's
some options like and of course for some
things you want to be in control you so
you want to be on this side of the of
the spectrum share the uncertainty with
me so right know about this in other
cases I don't actually care just give me
a reasonable result and then I'm ready
to move on there so maybe that's another
part of an answer tool to chametz
question you know where should we be in
which cases for which types of
information needs no
yeah now so I don't have the answer to
this with we've we've experimented a bit
for instance with talking with a
gigantic data set where you simply
cannot enumerate all of the columns in
in the table or in a very large cultural
heritage collection you cannot enumerate
thousands of paintings right
so what do you do and so there what we
actually fell back on after a while was
well a person can probably remember four
to six items and so they will well we'll
give them four to six items at most at a
time and then if we feel that we need to
go back to enumerated items depending on
how far how long it's been since we last
enumerated some items we have to repeat
some or we don't and so these are very
basic cognitive heuristics but yeah
that's where we are at the moment
I love the concept and actually yeah
yeah and yeah I mean we've it's it's
totally unclear what to do in many cases
so you've you've had this anti
vaccination vaccination or not
discussion here we've also had it in in
in the Netherlands and and so at one
point one of the the e-commerce sites
that we collaborate with in response to
a query about vaccination only showed
across the fault
I think anti vaccination results and so
someone took a screenshot and tweet it
and you know this ecommerce site is
totally bonkers or whatever the words
were that I used and well no because
they're a bit further down on the result
page that were results displaying a
different perspective on the on the
topic oh yeah what what do you do it's
once once the tweet is out there you're
lost and so what is what do you do then
yeah if you think if it's your value to
show diverse results in such cases
then maybe you should even that should
not be a one perspective above the fold
the other below the fold always you
should see the diversity apparently
right and that's well that's what they
decided to do in response to this
make sure that there's always if there
are multiple perspectives always show
them even on a small screen it's it's
probably this question that you asked
already we can probably get to
reasonably well performing and to
untrainable systems that that go quite
some some some way to what the goals
that I outlined now make them real make
them real in with all of these bells and
whistles that I mentioned with the
appropriate filters with more of a
pipeline based approach yeah so it's
taking taking these ideas well first
growing them further but I'm taking them
out of the lab you know oh we have one
more question
yeah no I agree and and so in many cases
viewing this well so far at least as a
planning problem is overkill and in many
cases you can get my perfectly fine
without reinforcement learning
just treat treated as a as a
classification problem or a hierarchical
classification problem perhaps and
that's it so far because of the
limitations that our data set and our
evaluation measures have yeah good point
all right thank you
[Applause]